my name is Jeffrey Yao I work at
Alliance Bernstein Accord masked monster
and I'm the chief data scientist I'm
also a faculty member at UC Berkeley I'm
teaching the data science program so
what we are going to talk about today so
treat this as a fairly high-level
introduction to two classes of models
for time series forecasting one is
vector October aggressions models which
has been developed for a long time and
used a lot by statisticians for
multivariate time series modeling and
then I also want to talk about similar
kind of models but using machine
learning or sorry similar kind of
problems but using machine learnings and
then I'll demonstrate how we actually
are going to implement that in Python
like I said I only have 25 or so minutes
to talk about to to class of models so
as you can imagine it's going to be
fairly high-level I won't be able to go
into a lot of the mathematical details
and then I want to compare their pros
and cons because these days there is a
myth that whenever used machine learning
you are going to build everything in
terms of the forecast so I want to see
if that's true
ok so it would be helpful at least for
this talk then you have some
understanding of the simple class of
autoregressive integrated moving average
model which is the univariate version of
the vector model that I'm going to talk
about today and then some understanding
of neural network techniques so the talk
today will have three parts one is the
motivation of why do we need
multivariate time series modelling and
then it's going into a little bit more
detail on Anwar vector regressions both
both of them it won't have the bank
I had this one off the light screen but
people in the back can hear me I think
yeah okay sure and then it's very
annoying and then the second part is a
particular kind of new network called
long short-term memory network which you
also saw in various talk already and
then a few remarks to compare the two
okay so why multivariate time series so
obviously one of the major use of time
series analysis is time series
forecasting in univariate time series
forecasting the direction is just one
way so using the past information to
forecast the future okay so which is
just like what describe this place so
you have let's say why is there a
variable that captured the series all
you have is the lack of the information
to fault out there now you can have a
slightly more complicated version of
that which is you also have extra genus
variable meaning unavailable that their
parts can also help you to forecast the
future of the variable Y series now so
the univariate type C model which is
this place in this formula which is a
type of October aggressive moving
average model with exogenous variable as
you can see right only the path of the
left value of of the Y variable as well
as the shocks which is denoted by omegas
here and the XS which are the exogenous
variable can affect the current value of
y right so one is saying is that if I
have multiple series that can interact
each other that y one for example can
affect y2 and y2 can also affect Y one
then the model that I just lay down here
will not be able to solve their problem
okay and so in fact we have the Nobel
Prize you know talking about economic
model today so the one model that I'm
talking about today is actually what he
called the reduce for model so meaning
it is not based on a particular
macroeconomic theory
that drive the whole movement of
multiple time series in fact a person
who make this model very very popular
for economists also got a Nobel Prize in
the same year that he got a Nobel Prize
so as you can see here so have in your
mental picture that if you have let's
say that someone I'm going to give today
let's say you have two series the each
series can affect each other in a
feedback loop framework then this model
could be a model to use so now whenever
you want to whenever your model VAR
there are some basic steps that then
that are good for practice so you want
to examine video you want to visualize
the data as well and for time series
there are special types of graphs that
allows you to look at the dependency
structure of the time series and then
you need to think about the
transformation yesterday I was in in one
of the talks some people asked about the
stationarity requirement when your model
time series and I'll talk a little bit
about those as well
and then of course you want to select
your model for the forecasting okay so
the example that I'm going to give today
I just create this example a couple of
days ago I try to use series that are
not found in textbooks or other papers
so I purposely chose this one for
example this one you can actually go and
download the data set and is the beer
sales in the United States so I download
the data from 1992 all the way to 2000
actually just three months ago and it's
measured in millions of dollars and the
other series that I want to use is the
Consumer Sentiment series okay so I want
to model them in a in a cone movement
way so again this is an this is where I
done the series as well is a very very
famous website then has a lot of more
than half a million series available
published by the Federal Reserve Bank
as st. Louis okay so again this to
website you can just go and download the
series so first thing is we want to
visualize the series okay so you just
have to I wrap off the functions here in
one of the functions in order to
visualize for graph there are always
plot when looking at one particular
series yes so so it is time series right
so looking just a histogram will not
allow you to capture the time element of
the series so you always want to look at
on the tab top left hand corner the
series itself over time right because
it's for example if you look only at the
histogram even though you saw a lot of
the values between 90 and 100 you don't
know where they're not they're clustered
with each other right as you can see in
the graph you can actually see the
sentiment value about 100 level both in
an ID and and getting very very close to
level in the mid 2000s as well the
bottom two graphs the graph that allows
you to look at the dependency structure
they're called octal correlation graph
autocorrelation function graph and the
other one is partial autocorrelation
functions each one of the bar in the
okto correlation function captured the
series itself and and how it is
correlated with its own path so for
example the first the the first bar
right there
capture the series itself and YT minus 1
the second part capture the correlation
between YT and mighty virus 2 etc etc
now this kind of graphs is actually very
very useful for you to identify the the
order of the ARIMA model ok the
univariate version of this now I do the
same thing for the BS series so as you
can see in the BS series number 1 is
very trendy it has an upward trend and
then also it has a lot of seasonality as
you can see here right so for us to use
the VAR model we actually have to take
care of some of these patterns before we
can fit into the model the seasonality
as you can see can also capture in the
optical relation function as well right
every 12 mono so you can see that the
correlation is is back up
I won't be able to go into this but I
always encourage people whenever you
even just plotting some graph underneath
us some estimate of some functions right
so as I can as I just said the bottom to
graph are the measure of autocorrelation
functions and partial autocorrelation
functions the terms are scary but
they're actually nothing more than just
estimate of some sort of correlations as
you can see over there it's just that
the correlation of the series itself and
its path okay that's why it's called -
so let me skip that
now I wanna mention a little bit about
the notion of stationarity because for
VAR model you need the stationarity
condition to be true in order for this
mathematical model to to use so there
are two notions of stationarity the
notions that we all.we we use in
practice is the weak notion of
stationarity all it is saying is that
the mean the variance structure and the
correlation structure do not change over
time okay now it's not saying that
they're constant it's not saying that
there is no dependence it's just saying
that the mean of the series itself is
constant the variance is constant and
then the correlation only depends on a
time lag so if you have YT + YK minus-1
the coalition would be the same as YT
minus v + YT minus X yeah otherwise you
won't have enough information to
identify to identify the model borrowing
the terms from borrowing some of both
professor Sutton said this morning you
need to put enough structure into the
model for you to identify some of the
parameters in a model and this is the
dependency structure that we impose on a
model in order to apply law now as you
can see from before the those two series
that we look at both of them are not
stationary okay so in fact both of them
are fairly trying trendy and
at least one of those also have the
seasonality in it and so just by
eyeballing it at least one of the first
try I want to give is to use the lock
difference transformation apply the lock
and then take the difference okay for
for the first series for the second
series actually need to apply the
seasonal differences in order to account
for the seasonality now so one of the
questions you may have is well I applied
the difference and then I apply the lock
as well so once i transformed the series
later on when you model the series you
just remember that you are modeling the
transform series so that when you do
forecasting you actually have an onion
transformer series before you can
actually apply to do to the forecast in
order to get back to the today the
original level of unit of measurements
so now in python it's actually very very
easy pendous it's actually this is
purposely designed for time series
analysis so there are many functions
within pendous there that if you have a
data frame you can already apply to it
so then the transformation right here
all you have to say is apply the lock
and then use the difference function at
the end to do the difference it's very
convenient okay now once you transfer
miss you it's always good to look at the
data again okay I know that you already
look at the data at the beginning but
always look at it after - in series to
make sure that you understand what's
going on
right because I use whitie - whitie -
trial for the beer series so I know that
at the beginning of the trial period I'm
not going to have any values because
there is no further path for me to
difference from right so I want to look
at it just to make sure that I did the
right thing okay so so that's that's
what I did right there
and after you transform a series
remember the the purpose of the
transformation is to make the series
stationary right so you want to look at
the series again at least visually to
convince yourself that the series is
stationary so that's what I did I report
the series again remember I write a
functions before so I can apply just to
any series that I have so we apply to
the transform series
and and and parties functions and so as
you can see all those correlations son
of disappear okay
some of them is still there but most of
them disappear okay so the the
non-stationarity is already taken care
off okay now so after that of course in
time series analysis you also have to
use the split the sample into training
and validation testing and validation
set now in time series you've got to be
really really careful when you do that
because you cannot just randomly select
other variables because of the because
of the dependency structure right so
what you do here is that at least from
this very simple example and leave our
few observations at the end for me to
validate my model in in real life
sometimes you have to use a boating
window so your estimate using you to
train your model using some of the
history and then you keep rolling
forward in order to test your model so
so I sell out the tests s just you know
just for myself to look at so I sell out
the last three period three months of
the data now even though this example is
fairly artificial I use only the
consumer sentiment and be ourselves the
two that I use here is really for for
the simplicity of illustration you can
easily extend this model to a fairly
large number so imagine if you have a
company that have many different selves
in many different regions let's say
thirty regions in the United States
you can actually apply this model as
well but of course you have to make sure
that this series are stationary and so
this you can imagine okay I want to
forecast the self on a monthly basis for
the next quarter okay but of course I
can also do it for the next one year as
well but again for illustration are
really for three months and I want to
forecast these three months and later on
I'm going to measure the performance of
my model against this this true value
these are already transformed that's why
the unit is kind of funny
remember the PSL is supposed to be in
million of dollars okay and then the
sentiment is you know [ __ ] shooting
between like sixty to a hundred or so so
we're that we can develop a Val model so
again because we're going to apply some
Python functions to estimate these
models is especially this car model is
actually a system of equations so it's
always a good idea to write down exactly
what you are trying to estimate later on
I'm actually going to estimate a lot all
with more variables this one is the
simplest form possible I only have two
equations and I only have two I only
have order of one so the way to read
this is that if you look at the first
equation y one key is a function of its
owner
y1 t minus 1 and also a function of y 1
y 2 t minus 1 in the second equations
only the left hand side variable is
different right which is white Y 2 u T
that is affected by the same two
variables right so if you only look at V
1 1 then measure the dependency of the
y1 series and its own path
if you look at V 2 2 in the second
equations that measure how the Y 30-1
effect or original series the other two
coefficients y 1 2 and then 1 sorry no I
went to V 1 2 and then 3 2 1 this
measure how the other series path effect
for example the BSU is or the sentiment
series okay that's how this kind of
system of equations allow you to capture
the dynamics between the two series and
so in many cases it can help improve the
prediction accuracy now of course
because you have a system of equations
you also have to specify or at least
mathematically in the back the variance
covariance structure of the series
itself ok
it's a stationary requirement I
mentioned it before this kind of model
required the series to be stationary if
the series are not stationary and this
in this simple case you have to
transform the individual series to make
it stationary so that you can fit it
into the model there are some other much
more complicated cases that I'm not
going to talk about which if you have a
background in time series you may know
of a concept called Co Co int equations
so if you have Co integrations amongst
you is you actually have to use other
kind of models related to this model so
cases under which var would be useful
well of course if you want to forecast a
collection if you want to forecast a
collection of variables without explicit
in interpretation this model
interpretation of each of those
coefficient this model would help now
actually the professor this morning he
already talked about economic theory
versus just a reduced form model so this
is a reduced form model in the back end
actually there is a structural model so
the structural interpretation of the
model based on economic theory is lost
in these kind of models but still use in
many many other disciplines for example
engineering okay if you want to test
whether one variable is useful in terms
of forecasting another variable this
this kind of model can help okay
he also showed it in Postma's form the
spawn analysis which you can also do in
Python as well but again the structural
shock and how does Sharpe affect the
series that meaning is already lost so I
just want to say one thing about
causality here the predictive predictive
causality so here what it really means
is that they are having analyses in your
system help you forecast the other
series okay that's all it is saying it
is not saying that you know when y y2 t
minus one move it will affect working
- one okay Waikiki why y1t okay this all
it means yeah okay so the model that I'm
actually going to estimate is this model
so it has three orders - two equations I
just have two more legs into it so I
have y YT minus 2 and also r YT minus 3
so in Python to estimate this model so I
use the libraries cause step models step
models actually have many many useful
regression types functions in it
one of those is VAR max models so I use
the TSA under the state's based library
the vector autoregressive and it also
has a moving average component but I'm
only going to specify the octo
regressive component so all you have to
do is when you call this API you have
your fit into the API the series that
you want to estimate and then the order
as well and we not only have the trend
so I'll pay you define a model and you
can fit the model okay and you can print
the result for whatever reason it
doesn't look out as nice but if if you
okay sorry
in my Jupiter notebook it's actually
printed where we're like nicely okay for
whatever reason when I ran other
interests lie the whip is not big enough
so each of this it give you first of all
the equation that the model that you
estimate the number of observations as
well as the estimate of the coefficients
okay so after that well you may wonder
why do you choose 3a arced var three why
not four why not - why not other orders
for example so there are different
method to select the model so in the
case of what this is called a selection
so all you have to select is the peak
right how many orders how many lack
orders you want and so one way to select
that is to use some sort of information
criteria AIC
see and then other information criteria
as well some more punitive than the
other and so you can literally estimate
a range of model select your final model
and then apply it to the original model
and print out the result which is
exactly what I did actually
okay now after that you have to turn off
your model right because after all we
have we put some fairly stringent
structure on the model you want to make
sure that the underlying assumption is
true now luckily for this card model the
we if the residual of this model solid
looked like white noise then it sort of
give you a confident that this does the
underlying assumptions of these models
are true so what I did was after you
estimate a model under the model object
one of those is actually the residuals
so you just have to print out the
residuals and then plot a graph to make
sure that it's solid look like white
noise okay so which is iid normal random
variable okay which is what I did here
both of them actually look like white
noise of course you can also apply some
more formal tests to make sure that the
normality assumption is true the
homoscedasticity is true and also the no
serial correlation or something is true
okay for the residual series okay I just
put this for for the sake of just
putting it you can do the impossible fun
functions here but like the professor
said this morning if it is not a
structural war some of the meaning is
lost okay forecast
so after estimate a model again if you
only look at the code sometimes you can
get loss because I applied the
differences and then difference are in
different order and then I also apply
the law as well and so sometimes it's
easier if you write it down so that you
can
you can reverse transform to make sure
that what kind of formula you need to
write down in your Python code before
you transform the series so just a few
line of algebra you know that after you
estimate what I call Z here okay if you
want to get your series sorry if you
want to get your forecast
you have to exponentiate that difference
and then multiply by the series plus
whatever okay
I find it easier if you write on the map
first before you go to the right out of
code okay and then I also write down the
formula so actually the first very first
model I try is actually a bad one but
the as you can see I actually try bar
three okay this is I just what do I have
here okay well this is actually the the
forecast of the series sorry the label
is not good the one on the right hand
side is actually the forecast this is
the forecast of the sentiment series as
you can see using a simple VAR model
like this already have a pretty good
performance okay
which might be a series I care about
being a serious as well but oh maybe
it's right here okay so so after after I
do that you have to calculate the
forecast error I calculate this as a
benchmark because later on well a few
more minutes I need to talk about the
new network model I want to see whether
or not I can beat the forecast in this
case is the root mean square error is
176 remember these are a million of
dollars okay
and when I check in the last several
months the BSA is around four point four
four point five billion US dollar so 176
176 million dollar or narration that
this model is off okay for one month
forecast okay so for the next three
months so if you divide that by the
amount which is less than five percent
of the forecast error okay using a very
very simple model that I actually
haven't read it
okay now this pie is going to be fast
because I just want to make sure you
know how to implement it there are two
other talks they also at least two other
talks that I'm into
they'll also talk about ASTM just really
quick the reason I use ASCII rather than
typical new networks they're a typical
new network the feed-forward time your
network doesn't piece of memory okay
these are time series this a time series
data you want the past information to be
preserved when you train your model so
that that gets to return your network
okay but why do I not use so the
following sky I'm just going to skip
over it because of the details so why do
I use ASTM rather than a typical week on
your network well the reason being a
typical week on your network actually
has a very hard time learning long time
dependency okay so if the information
that are from very remote past
the typical RNN cannot learn it because
of a lot of those multiplications of the
weights that's going on so you need a
STM in order to apply a concept called
gate in order allow or control
information that's so true from the past
to the curve and that's the only reasons
why I use an SDM there are different
implementation of this so in general
these are the steps that I would follow
through for STM now this car model is a
lot more difficult to specify versus the
versus the the bar model that you see
the bottom order they usually are
literally I have the series a plot the
series I specify the model literally in
a in a couple of lines right now this
car model first of all because
everything within a new network should
be considered as a tensors vectors if
you will or high dimensional arrays so
so you have to make sure that your data
set is conformed into those
format so Joey yesterday talked about
you know a lot of data pre-processing
which is definitely true here so again I
need to know
and pasta series already loaded right
it's the same example and I formerly the
serious using the RNN as well so so here
is how I you need to write at least a
few lines in Harlequin value or code
that is suitable for this kind of
program okay because the this the new
network itself would not be able to tell
what Lex do you want to use as the input
features so you have to specify the
features yourself what information to
look at yes we did
now scaling the series so previously I
didn't do scaling right in the bond
model what I did was I transformed the
series so that it is stationary here on
the other hand there is no requirement
about stationarity although if you fit a
serious daily stationary is easier for a
model to run but it's not a requirement
and in fact in my example I did not
transform into stationary stationarity
oh the only thing I did is to scale the
series you have to scale the series
because a lot of the weight in the
series you don't want the unit of your
series to be too different from the
weight okay my is like several thousands
right as you can see before and so there
are different scale that you can use I
in this case you apply some psychic line
I just use the standard scale in this
case min max is another one that I use a
lot as well but in this case I chose the
stennis kala meaning you normalize the
series to have means your and standard
deviation of one okay okay okay
this is it's the key point one dimension
so to specify the model itself there
were simple element you want to specify
the number of neurons the layers that
you want to use the activation functions
you want to use how many layers as well
as the two important things the last
functions in this case I use mean square
error as well as the optimizer okay
these are the things you have to choose
of course each and every single one of
these can be tuned and so that's why
this car mode is so much more difficult
to dispense about than the other one
and then you train the model and then
you produce the forecast so here
actually for the very first this I'm
done so the very first one then I drink
actually perform much worse than the
other one that you just saw but then I
want you to optimize try to optimize the
model so I include I include the
complexity of the model to include more
new ones in this case actual was able to
beat the original forecast so the lowest
MSE that I got a sexual 124 so let me
jump to not yet
yeah not that don't look afresh yet okay
comparison of the approach so really
quick VAR model so voir model would be
useful for financial times is
forecasting if you want to model them in
a system of equation way however there
are many problems that can be solved by
new network that cannot be solved by bar
model I just this is few here for
example time series classification voir
model I have rarely heard people use one
four times its classification anomaly
detection you can also see people useful
but then of course ASTM even in other
talks you saw people apply to NLP you
you saw people apply to image processing
so while model is not possible okay the
model is a lot more difficult to train
compared to bar but why it's very easy
and for many of the series actually
works really well okay I'm running out
of time unfortunately professor took up
all my time so thank you as all I have
we are hiring as well
[Applause]